having a guy like Garfunkel who sings
beautifully he's your security blanket
then we fast forward to when you finally
have had enough and you know Artie's off
making his movies and he's not playing
the game with you anymore and he's
keeping you waiting in the studio what
was going on in the studio though was a
a real tug of war about taste and how to
do it
we didn't agree about you know we were
friends since we're 12 years old but our
musical inclinations are quite different
and so we would have disagreements and
the disagreements could be you know real
arguments that could stop you know stop
a session it's cold so I said to Artie
are you going to go and do another movie
now and he said yeah and I said why
didn't you tell me I just heard it from
Chuck Rhoden he said I was afraid if I
told you you would stop working on
Bridge Over Troubled Water and I thought
I gotta get out of here yeah good for
you